[Music]
psychology today we're gonna talk a lot
about the Italian and maybe some events
because I've had bunch of advance thing
play with me recently on the stream and
it's been going fun so why not let's
look at that too so I played a lot
against Italian with black there are a
lot of different variations a lot of
different ways to play it and it's been
like I play there a lot with different
openings different ways and so far I
think I'm happy with what I found and so
I'd like to share that with you today so
let's dive in so this is the typical
position for Italian and I'm a big fan
of just playing Bishop c5 I don't really
like to play this nice have six lines
but I've tried it before so for me
Bishop c5 so here if b4 then we got
advance if c3 with d3 that's the closed
Italian and then there is one with d4
yeah whoops d4 and so that's hopefully
I'll get to cover all of its for you
today let's start with the basics like
c3 so with c3 well sorry I am sorry
that's would be my ad from the other
laptop connecting me to YouTube
haha hello everyone I see Nixon I see
Brian Clark hi hi Peter okay so
so here let's go just look at the simple
knight f6 there is d 3 there is d 4 and
recently there has been bunch of a force
the idea of a fort that has been
emerging but let's just look at the d 4
first so after D for taking is the main
one now White has different
possibilities there is Castle there is a
5 unders take so let's look at take
first because that's something that it's
been played most after check
neither is 3 nights 3 legal moves but
two good moves the nice counter sitting
in the bishop coming today - so Bishop
coming to d2 that's one of the most
famous ones because there is this take
take d5 and people tend to think of it
as a repetition a lot it's a way to do
this repetitions and so that's something
that I've seen a lot happen but you as
black if you don't want the repetition
you don't have to do it and you can
simply play Knight to e7 Knight back to
e7 to protect your knight over here and
your future plans with BC 6 to enforce
this night and get this Bishop out to f5
or g4 and to work on this isolated pawn
so let's say for example after 97 you
get castle
so here actually I had gained whoops
that's my fault
oh that is still my fault I didn't know
there we go now it's fixed so I had a
game that I played with under when I was
playing the iewk championships in Asia
and I really hated to make draws because
I wanted to keep fighting and fighting
so I came up with some of the things
that my opponent didn't like and so I I
looked this I remember right before the
match and I got the position that I
wanted with c6 and it's not it's just
something that I wanted to follow the
strategy that I knew and so I was really
working on that to get the bishop out to
start working on the D for weakness and
we are still looking at everything from
black side so that there was a question
in chat so for example all right
so one thing to keep in mind is this
position if you get into endgame with
black that's something that you want so
this Queen b6 could be a possibility to
think about to think about because let's
say if rook e1 you get Queen b6 if take
you simply take with pawn and now you
have another weakness to attack and you
can start playing like this and go after
d4 pawn so it's just really safe
basically so my opponents blade Knight
e4 I still followed my plan I did the
awesome pin so now here I want to ask
audience what you want to do with black
you see your knight isn't your night is
under attack with this one your Bishop
is under attack with that night but do
you want to move the bishop or do you
want
you let this exchange happen so let's
see who wants to play what what's offer
my using chess face time I grew up the
chest face I am a chess bass fan I like
the way it organizes files and
everything so Connor wants to play
Bishop g6 interesting any other Bishop
takes e4 possible but you would be
giving your opponent a lot of activity
so maybe think of something that doesn't
give white activity and you're
activating your pieces maybe Bishop e6
Knight f4 right aphorism I'm a little
worried after night at 4 Queen goes to
f3
so if you play Bishop e6 the thing is
Knight g5 and you are still going to
lose this Bishop just in the worst way
because you have to stop them eight so
something like g6 and take take it
whoops take and near pawn structure just
God's really unpleasant so this should
be six if you want to play Bishop e6
then you have to have considered ninety
five so uh yeah thank you for those of
you who are suggesting move it moves
with drug yeah rook the eight we've seen
it is simple if you take on at five I'll
take back when you take the knight on
here I just take back with the rook
I'm already bringing everything to
attack your pawn over here
so now I'm attacking two of your pawns
yeah exactly clean b2 might be coming up
- good - uh Nixon so ah this is what's
happened in the game as well because at
this point if well why didn't take here
d4 is is still following b2 is is still
falling so something in like rook d1 and
there is the possibility of taking on b2
whoops sorry there is your P one there
is there a nice queen takes d4 nice no
there are no tactics here if the other
were close however now you do have Queen
takes before because you end up with the
last Queen d4 but be careful with this
little Queen traps
now you can I think simply just keep on
putting more pressure on d4 it should be
good enough something like night before
you move the Queen somewhere and you
lose this night yeah
everything should be very pleasant
enough yep Kirk d8 Queen takes P - yeah
those are coming up all right so now
what do you think wise can do is there
any way for a wife to try and defend
this pond
something like immediate Slyke direct
direct defense doesn't really work
because just I just take it back
same for Luke Tiger coming to c4 I can
just simply take it back so any on any
indirect ways to protect this pawn
I'm seeing a lot of roopd ones and rooks
ephors
but I'm still not really working so one
thing that white could do to try and
slightly trick me is rig c5 because
after rook c5 if you take there's take
with pawn and now the pawn structure is
getting strong or take with Knight
attacking this night as well
so after rook comes to c5 one thing that
you shouldn't do it black is take that
truck now is it possible to take over
here take on d4 or would you rather just
play something more strategic
I do see some noxee fives nice
I think the problem is if you take
Knight takes d4 rook takes on d5 cd5 and
something like Knight c3 and now it's
white who's starting to attack your upon
a little and you're giving quite clear
weakness so that's why something like 94
wouldn't work I mean it works but
preferably you want to try for more so
I'm gonna York fth good one good on
fragrance and because close stunning 451
yeah me too I'm not the biggest fan of
something like rickety for as well
good one good one Emma dogs because yeah
Knight f6 looks cool doesn't it you take
Queen takes a five and now white got a
lot of activity
yeah alright so I'm glad we all agree on
Drop coming to d8 great
so after recording it you still have all
of those threats plus more now you want
to take on c5 whoops now if it's black
to move again black wants to take on c5
because it's attack the two and there's
this pin so this guy is falling so
that's why white kind of has to take and
after rook takes d5 you take back with
rook so you are still have all of the
pressure on d5 and also keep your pawn
structure all nice ninth goes to c3 now
what do you want to do this is so this
is super easy intermediate moves I know
all of you can find that I just need
someone to say it
nice to see I have some Persian audience
yeah good one Connor Queen takes d4 and
everything is safe this is an end game
that should be easily winnable the rook
is more active you have a more power do
you have this maturity pawn just have to
be careful not to play inaccurate moves
alright so here after Queen takes d4
claim goes to C let's say clean goes to
C - there're few moves left in the game
so I'm going to show you
so you're black you know that you have
advantage but how can you make progress
so what do you want to do ideally some
sort of a plan or like next 2-3 moves
like where do you want your rook to be
your knight your queen some some stuff
like that
while you think I'm gonna tell you a
little bit of background story on this
game too so this was an aging new 2013
and I won that championship and it was
my second gold in aging news
and it was a nice tournament I liked
everything I mean because I want it and
it was I think 2013 was one of the early
years that I started to see chess as
something more serious than just a game
for me
so basically afters like second year
that I want Asian Championship
I started thinking it could be more than
just a happy and so that was kind of
funny and yeah so I'm not entirely sure
about the Phaedo rules right now but I
after I won this tournament I realized
that oh well since it was under 16 after
I want it I got one W I am norm and I
realized that I already had like two
that would be that this was my my second
W I am there and I was like wow cool
well just need one more to go and punch
a rating so that was kind of interesting
yeah alright so let's get back to the
chess aspect of it so we have rook c5
Queen d2 Ricky five thank you
we have Josh Friedel in the chat welcome
welcome
so there I feel like something like
Queen d2 is also clear and nice but
Queen d2 you might give the chance for
like something like maybe Queen comes to
e4 and activating the Queen so just
what's the dorsal style not giving any
chance to your opponent's so maybe I
like that those of you who suggested
rocky 5 I like it
so right also suggest g6g six is the
next move coming up soon because you
want to open some room for your King to
breathe so that's something that you're
gonna do sooner or later
preferably sooner and so I like 35 just
because it's created more opportunities
and took away the rookie ones and all of
those so thank you
yeah thank you Maddox okay so it comes
to e5 let's say of t1
what do you want to do that's black it's
important to be able to keep your cool
and win the game after you have
advantage because sometimes when you
have advantage and it's not like a clear
tactic or a clear end game it's easy to
mess it up so let's let's try to win
beautifully over here
well actually someone already said what
to do so I'm just gonna go ahead
yeah I'm onyx truth it cooks it is also
there sista good one there is no way you
can say that name but I'm going to try
matter that's have already said it
correctly and also Nixon yep
j6 good one so the whole idea is you're
not going to take it because I meet you
and to put it simply and yeah so g6 is
pretty cool my opponent played g3 now
where do you want to put your queen
when g4 I think when g4 is definitely
interesting
I mean c5 I think I don't think there is
like a right square forward to put the
Queen but I really wanted to have this
queen support the rook so I went Queen
c4 and then Queen e6 because I wanted to
start trying to create chances in the
open file and I didn't want my opponent
to keep attacking my queen so I just
went back I hid behind the rook and now
it's time to start pushing some pawns so
some pushing and protecting my pawns now
so I can someone finish this game please
this is
remember this is a very lonely king
these are very ready pieces
any fun checks any fun sacrifices
yeah all right everyone sees it - for a
good one take check and it's already bye
bye see you next game because kinga
phone is the only one that prolongs it
by one move hands bye-bye
so this was a very interesting game for
me cuz I do remember she was one of the
opponents that I had to face every every
youth Asian Championship and I was just
like I can't wait to be done with my
category and yeah it was it was one of
those opponents that he always played so
it was nice to beat her cool right
alright so let's go back to our main
Italian so we just looked at some ideas
with this 97 now there there are some
ones that have been emerging and Queen a
tree seems to be coming up and what is
right so if here with white you're
looking up for something to look look at
it's this Queen a tree because it makes
it more uncomfortable for black to
Castille and play c6 and there is
another line if your opponent plays like
Knight a5 Queen a4 check and then Queen
a tree that's another one so these are
just some stuff to think about with
white and so let's we looked at this
Bishop d2 defense now let's take a quick
look at Knight c3 so after Knight c3 I
played two games that's we're very
interesting and so in both of them I
took on e4 I do remember something with
Bishop c3 as well earlier I gave this a
try too
and here what do you think wise should
do
I want to test your knowledge for white
because why not
and white does have different
possibilities to try and yeah there is a
possibility of take on a seven maybe
something to try and maneuver on that
there should be d5 already so let me
know what you want to do with whites
Queeny - yeah I
I'm singing um if Queen comes to you -
what about d5
so if Bishop takes f7 king takes f7 what
now do you think that's something that
actually works for Bishop of seven is a
little too early for me I'm kind of a
fan of d5 thinking about it cuz d5 you
gotta move the knight and then you get
some Bishop D trees and you can give
some check that's the first thing that
comes to my mind but Bishop d5 also yeah
after take bishop d5 is also a good
possibility Knight f6 and what do you
want to do now advice
Castells are always possible at this
point
but yeah 94 makes it slightly gives a
lot of chance to white so that's
something that we don't want to do and
after take Bishop c3 is not the best
because after Knight takes e4 with wack
your position has lots of holes and it's
simply not worth it because after Knight
c3 take-take-take on e4 the easiest way
for whites to play is to d5 still in
whoops
in my opinion still just e5 and if you
go on I to a 5 your knight is really
looking to be easily trapped over here
and now you're gonna move this light and
they're always Bishop a trees at least
they're trying to close up and then some
checks coming up so why its position is
way more active for just one pawn so d5
it would be my first choice
and if 97 there are still lots of I'm
just thinking about Queen e2 running
with d6 maybe Bishop e3 maybe d6 now
whoa so many possibilities
I still like Queen e2 to be honest if
Knight goes to d6 trying to close up a
little bit
even if cast oh this is really how are
you gonna get this Bishop out I have
cast oh I have night g5 I have Bishop g5
everything seems to be going pretty
decent for black yeah so no need to try
to play around with this Bishop c3 one
other thing that I wanted to show you
was with Bishop d2 there is another line
like with with black you don't have to
take it on you don't have to take d2 so
there is a slightly tricky line with
Knight takes e4 but it's still it
doesn't feel like it's it has that much
gain to it
so night xe4 Bishop takes before you
take back and your idea is if Queen b3
too early now you have t5 and you get to
this position you get your castle and
now you have this week want to go after
with no bishops on the board for white
so that's just a simple idea like that
but the best line for white is to
actually take this Bishop takes f7 after
King of seven now give a check and there
is possible but it's not the most
desired one fun fact King e6 is actually
interesting here so yeah if King g6 the
Queen before there's a bunch of Queen d6
it gets a little weird and game but it's
doable and it's quite interesting so
there's that yeah why does play Bishop
f7 in this line and wax idea is to just
like do this fake kind of cast off
either we took on f8 or yate and try for
this but I don't I'm not the biggest fan
of this line because there is this 95s
and the knight gets really strong so
just if you're playing with white
remember to take it first and give it an
Queen b3 so someone asked to show this
line with white so basically it's the
simple Italian open Italian and after
take we looked at Bishop d2 and the idea
with Knight takes e4 this is what we
were looking at just right now yeah yep
that is true you there are isolated
ponds everywhere and King e6 was very
interesting I played that in a few rapid
games rapid and blitz games it was fun
but the end game wasn't really how do
you say that wasn't for me it was
interesting but not my top choice of end
game to be honest so yeah
all right so let's just go back to the
good old knight c3 that's people love to
play so here take castle we all know
this lines writes this fun d5 so d5 is
the main one but taking is also
something that has been played so let's
say Weiss doesn't know they have to play
d5 and just take early on now what do
you want to do with black in testing
your knowledge right here right now King
f8 instead of d5 server well d5 in that
position d5 is something that some kind
of it's good to do it because you're
stopping a check you're opening your
bishop and if you play King f8 your rook
you don't know what to do with your rug
so yeah
yeah d5 here good on so after d5 uh I
had someone play Bishop III with me and
someone play Bishop d3 with me so let
like for example if Bishop III I think I
think Bishop III is the more knowing one
because if something like Bishop d3 you
just get your castle and next you are
trying to go Bishop g4 so like h3 and
it's very playable with black so we are
gonna look at something like with Bishop
a tree and so here after Bishop 8 whoops
after Bishop e3 what do you want to do
with black well kind of weird to ask
because we were showing it on screen but
still how do you want to try and cast Oh
with black
do you want to try and take the bishop
or
oh yeah hi yep we are alive
how do I work on endgame specific both
are studying for me the way I wanted to
play this with the way I understood end
games was mainly practical so I tried to
understand what am I looking for in that
end game and then I just tried to play
it out
mmm the one book that I absolutely loved
was the dead word scam game so this is
not it's a mix of games not just mine
but yeah I am I did see in the chat
someone mentioned fragrance yeah
the Seamus Lasker that's the game I was
actually going to share right now
because so in this game that I played I
was a kid and I didn't know the games of
my big guys by heart so I chickened out
and I played Bishop e6 but Bishop d6 d4
taking the bishop is the best line and
this is the game between CH danaans and
Lasker in 1896 whoa so that's something
to keep in mind I'm gonna show you this
game quickly because it was very
beautiful and I really enjoyed it so
after like D take C for the main thing
to be worried about is rook e1 right f5
to keep your knight and try and create
some room for your king you run away
with the King because if you don't f3 is
coming up
least of all take take take now looking
for could be a serious threat Queen f3
could be a serious threat so Queen f6
should be your main move Queen e2 is
what Shane explained
now blacks you move what do you want to
do for those of you who know it maybe
give like 20 seconds before saying to
move I was born in Iran moved here in
2017
f5 was weird why not Queen D flat
because of Queen d5 there was to answer
so so sink if Queen d5 there was 92 and
then f3 it kept spinning your knight and
eventually pick it up
there was one good endgame book that was
very practical it was like thousand
tactics and amp games and it just showed
the tactical aspects of endgame I'm
getting some Knight a5 Bishop d7 Bishop
e6 yeah thank you
I was waiting to see Bishop a5 alright
so Zack are you
Bishop a good one coin tags
what do you want to do with your king d5
it would be annoying yeah it's the price
you pay for having an extra piece right
so something if you're still talking
about Queen d5 instead of f5
well after 92 your night is kind of
falling so the idea is to try and keep
the night we could try and go back to
position after we look at the game yep
Thank You Josh Widow King g6 and
everybody else who are saying King g6
all right so
kangjae six and it feels pretty safe
doesn't it were close to a tree you
might want to try and give me some
checks
who cares about checks I'm gonna try and
exchange some rocks and now this might
be getting a little bit too real so we
are gonna run away with our King so now
everything is safe right
you're just one piece up and just have
to show a little bit more technique and
win the game just like last scared it
right
we like last gear don't we all right so
I'm gonna stop showing this game here
because it should be doable and you just
please don't blunder and keep activating
your pieces yeah hi Manuel yeah all
right glad glad everyone are what would
whites have played to flag them play
Bishop d6 instead of Bishop f5 so I
guess you were asking here if Bishop e6
[Music]
the one thing that I am thinking of but
I don't know if I should be it's just d5
take check pick this guy up
to answer ech ech Phu I guess that's
yeah I think that's the easiest way to
see what why Bishop e6 is wrong and
there was another question while back
about Queen d5 here that I said Queen
d530 92 least of all and I have five F 3
and I picked this Knight up and then you
also can't Castle so it's a sad position
if there should be six just pick this
Knight up with whichever piece you want
and you are trying to just keep your
pieces
alright glad thank you thank you flip
all right so I guess everyone's happy
with this game so am I DC for so if
you're black and your opponent plays
weird stuff you take the piece but know
what you're doing don't don't just fall
into traps alright
hi storm alright so in the game I didn't
know what I was doing and so on it
slightly chickened out and I played
Bishop e6 and I'm gonna show you where
quickly why Bishop e6 made my games a
little bit miserable Bishop d3 I try to
still go for castle and I got myself
into this position so lovely right
because if I take with Queen
unfortunately there is 95 yeah trying to
see if this works I don't think it does
because there's this Bishop f5 at the
end so this that doesn't work but simply
Knight to g5 and it's making my position
very uncomfortable already least of all
there's take and now come blood deal
with this pawn structure so that's why I
just took here and fill
really miserable I'm remember I was a
kid I was what like 12 years old 13
years old so this is not my most proud
game I'm just showing you some things to
do is white let's go with that and there
is a very cute tactic that I want to
show as well that's my opponents minused
so the kid that I was I went through the
tricky mates so tricky right and still
trying to trick my opponents still
pushing for more some more pushings and
here I played recap 6 which was not my
best choice of move but can someone tell
me how can white get immediate advantage
I am thinking about
then Bensimon that's sorry my bad that's
the wrong name for the game this game
was 2011
sorry not a database this is against a
guy named Cavani and it wasn't 2011 my
back
hmm you guys are nuts that's I'm I'm
kind of pleased to see I'm not the only
one who missed it
yeah at rates going for the two rooks
that's the good one yeah so you should
take over here take that and it's not
two rooks it's two rooks and the bishop
that's the that's the fun part of it so
yeah
Queen f6 is the easiest one because
remember guys your checks and takes do
you see any reasonable check here
not really what are your takes taking on
CA taking on this rook taking on here
that doesn't work taking on c6 it's also
weird so always always to take a little
breather to look at all the checks and
takes so now my opponent played queen c5
and I got advantage because I managed to
double my rooks up and give this lovely
check and it's it's very nice to be able
to finally get mate right all right so I
wanted to share this line about 93 and
why it is wrong to take back immediately
so I'm gonna show you very briefly on
not to take back so defy all right first
of all I'm gonna give a second to talk
to you see on the chat if there are any
questions or recommendations on what to
do in this position
because a lot of you guys already know
it but um it's never a bad idea to
refresh your memory
now is it
so
yeah you gotta get back to f6 that is
true yep so
there has been some some people have
tried 95 which seems seemed because
little too old seems to be interesting
95 was played by like Karpov and
Dominguez and one belly and they they
gave it a try
years ago 10 years 20 years ago but it
has this there is one other game but
this 95 seems to be not so pleasant
mainly because just take on c3 and then
after take on c3
with white you kind of already have a
little bit of the edge and so now if you
take here there is Queen e2 and
attacking both mines Knight d6 there's
92 92 and so that's um it's doable worth
to try if you want to with black but
yeah so basically Bishop f6 is the way
to go whoops Bishop f6 is the way to go
whoa for a second I keep touching my
Knights
alright so let's play Bishop f6 and now
everything is kind of very fast forward
for whites and now you take this guy you
want to play this d6 early on so you
open your Bishop up if not these six
with white is coming and after that
Bishop g5 seems to be the main one there
are some some stuff with like Bishop b5
as possibilities too but I'm just trying
to show you what to look for with white
and black hawk to Brasilia of course
Thank You Manuel
I was in Brazil 2011 I liked it
my name is Caleb Tammy - he should be
here tomorrow
95 keep spawning citrine yeah there are
correct yeah so glad to know we are all
on board with our openings haha so I'm
just gonna show you really quickly so we
can move on to more tricky stuff so here
let's look at Bishop g5 because seems to
have the most oops sorry
seems to have the most interest alright
so
so after Bishop g5 take you take with
night
the wanting to keep in mind with black
is that your castle is going to be very
hard to do because you don't really want
to deal with this queen is five we're
taking an English five and very
unpleasant isn't it so that's why and if
you even if you put H six now that also
doesn't work because of Queen is five so
here are some things to keep in mind so
what do you think black should do
I might be trying to trick you about
castle on h6 so don't take my word for
it just some things to think about I do
like to be a little tricky on chat so
what do you want to do with black
yeah so josh freese oh I stopped in
person is in Caleb
why a few days ago I might start in
person I think here again came again
soon but we'll see we'll see if the
twitch moobot lets me have my own name
or not yeah okay so Wow there are a lot
of there are a lot of different
suggestion so yeah Bishop Bishop f5 is
not ideal because you do run into Queen
of five but Queen - five there's Bishop
three six King f8 Oh lovely there's so
many suggestion I thought this was a
very well-known line never mind never
mind
okay so alright let's get back to the
chess aspect of it so full transparency
h6 does work because if Queen comes h5
now you can just cast on and there you
kind of avoided the threats you're
protecting your epsilon and there is no
truth on h7 anymore so your score good
age six is the best one I was trying to
trick you like glad it works a little
bit and castle night h7 is still a
possibility and then take and check and
wreckage for you still could try to run
away with like you gotta move to F pawn
so we'd like f5 I guess but I I wouldn't
really recommend this
not something you want to see and like
move 1314
so actually 15 well here is 16 never
mind
but still don't don't let don't give
your opponent too many chances so don't
do that early cast on do the h61
with the idea of cast on and after age 6
Queen e2 is the best one for white
because white is putting up some more
pressure take Ricky one now you don't
want to allow this rope coming to
seventh rank so it's a good idea to
block it off after take you play your
app six a little bit and so now your
idea is to try and open up here a little
bit depending on how fast or how slow
white plays if you're lucky you might be
able to do long castle but it's highly
unlikely so another thing that you can
try and do is get you a king over here
and why it's idea is to come and
exchange this rook and give some checks
so here is the here's the summary of
what to look for from here on out
good luck let me know how it turns out
when you play a few games all right
what happens after h6 Queen h5 you just
play castle to answer in my dogs
oh that's cool Stern it's not like it's
not it's not like you're it doesn't feel
like a sacrifice because you are going
to lose a piece right now it's just a
matter of which one to lose all right
yeah the position is a little bit risky
and that's kind of the price of having
more pawns you're paying that price but
yeah it's not my stop my first choice to
have all right so that's all I wanted to
show you for the open Italian there
would there is a funny line with E 5
that could be that you can get to this
position with different possibilities a
lot so there's that too and so here so
all right I'm gonna take a little pause
so everyone's caught up and feel comfort
comfortable and if they have suggestions
we can see that too
Thank You Josh yeah you ideally you want
to get your pieces out yeah
Tran Queen Clarke yeah you want to bring
out c6 and get your queen out in the
previous position I am a woman GM and I
am
okay all right yeah
how is it really feeling on this any
suggestions to share about this position
thank you thank you sir
no one no one wants to say anything all
right that's okay so the best line for
whites to approach it is take so I'm
gonna briefly show you some of the fun
mistakes that people usually do one of
them is take which is you just take with
clean and voila you are at least upon up
you and you just cast oh and thanks you
bring up Bishop g4 and everything is
lovely all right just some of the stuff
that's white sometimes do and as black
you can tank them there is this 94 to
that people like sometimes but you can
simply cast off and if take take if take
there's Queen h4 and if not the later on
sooner than rather later you're gonna
play Bishop a6 what else what else is
there for white not to do same with
taking with night there are still lots
of idea with Queen h4 take take and
sacrificing this rook with Bishop a6 so
there are some ideas taking back with
pawn is the most common one and all
right some people play Bishop b4
my friend says that this should be six
to keep the pressure on d4 I'm gonna
take another breather and see how
everyone is doing on chat maybe get some
recommendations suggestions
how do you get to this he 4590 f3 knight
c6 Bishop c4 Bishop c5 c3 Knight f6 d4
take E 5 and then you do d5 y sack the
rook it's just it's a possibility that
I've tried in some blitz games it feels
nice and you are certain answer bro
arena you are playing Bishop a6 to stop
why it's castling so that's why
thank you drank wine Clark
you need Whiteside I know right I've
done so much white in the last few
lessons that we've had I decided to do
some black perspective too
all right nobody has any questions here
all right
I can't force you but so as black your
idea is pretty clear you're gonna get
that guy out you're gonna do this and f6
or f5 so that's your general idea as
white white can try to put a street to
stop it or the white can't try to play
Knight c3 over castle so that's just
those are just some of the things and
I'm gonna show you just one game because
I don't want to get into too much
details all right so this is a game that
I played again kit doors up late and
2013 why are we showing so many telling
2013 why did I have so much Italian
happen during 2013 right 2013 should be
renamed the Italian name all right so I
had the idea to just simply get my
pieces out and this was in World Youth
Championship okay so if h3i still was
going to try and open the position like
that a little bit and here is this
really cute tactic tactic I can't say
tactic haha and it's very interesting
it's definitely worth a try but be sure
to look into it more detail because
depending on where the King go because
King goes back it's a blunder and King
comes to f3
there is Bishop d4 and then you're
trying to get this guy out and work f8
and it's very lovely
I was so waiting for some opponent to
let me play this night f2
you never got it in real life the
opening variation I thought I did with
evil no this was yeah this was 2013 this
was way way before all right
so Knight c3 Bishop g4 Bishop e2
I've had some opponent to play Bishop
III with me and I've always tried this
f5 because I feel like it's a slightly
tricky to cuz if you take it all right
great I just take it back if you don't
take it then you play something just to
develop then I have this f4 coming up so
something to keep in mind what's my
ranking on leeches I'm not this I'm not
the biggest fan of leeches no disrespect
just I grew up loving chests 24 sorry I
have a good rating there I like to keep
it so an chests calm but still chest on
it for yeah when you live in Spain you
get consumed by chests 24 couldn't help
it alright so let's say up on a place
Bishop eats you there are a lot of
different variations like black just
like deal with this and then there is
like some weird variations that you can
maybe take some stuff it can gets really
weird really quick so be careful not to
just exchange everything off my advice
but yeah it is very pleasant because now
you get this pin and you're attacking
this one so eventually white will take
on c6 usually anyways
so we got this will be too so my
question to you guys do you want to try
and go for this one or do you want to do
you see any reason to like play Bishop
f3 or do you want to continue with our
plan with like f6 or f5
I did partner with just 24 briefly and I
did some videos for them it was fun I
like that
why are we moving a six
oh we are not moving a six yet why
aren't we well the thing is white but
Jovan v5 is very unstable so Wyatt would
have to move it eventually so that's
something that like a six would kind of
be a waste of temper
what if Queen d3 the d4 pawn is is still
very sad
so black to move what do you want to do
okay so you want to take you want to
play f5 or f6 alright so no one wants
okay I have one person who wants to take
the eight why not let's take a look so
if take take take on d4 Bishop c4
because if Knight takes there is the
possibility of losing the while not
losing but not having to Bishop and as
ytu would prefer to keep more pieces why
not if Knight takes here there's Queen
d5 and losing upon like that and in a
game I didn't really see this like I
deal with f5 I thought this was a little
too good to be true but if it was right
now I think this is the line whoops I
would pick Queenie five
yeah trying to break down center very
good f6 is coming up you guys are a
little behind sorry
so yeah that's all idea that we would
want to get the Queen out to in the
center and we are attacking this little
guy a little bit
oh well good night
Tran Queen Clarke well this will be on
YouTube later so come back and see
alright so if it was me right now I
think I would and if I saw that idea
with f6 which is doable but sometimes
stuff can slip I would definitely go for
this but in the game I rush it a little
and I played f6 and I saw that there
there are some ideas with just stuff
like that and I wanted to avoid that so
I went King ish gate that after take out
I realized that oh whoops well I can't
take with Queen because Knight takes d5
King h8 I if I remember correctly from
my side felt like a blunder at the game
because I if if my King was still on g8
I could simply play Knight takes c3 and
Queen takes f6 but because my king is
not on g8 anymore I kind of decided to
give up an exchange for activity so to
put it this way I slightly blundered in
the game at the 15 year old or so
slightly blundered but successfully
managed to get back and play actively so
there's that
all right so what I was thinking about
was if my opponents could play something
like this but it is way too passive cuz
now it's just two bishops against a to
pieces against the rook and that's very
nice for me but 95 is the kind of a
killer move if I take on te two I can
actually get really uncomfortable it is
possible this is still very doable
whoops sorry I keep forgetting there's a
queen under attack but this is still
very doable but I was hoping for more in
the game so I decided to not exchange
the bishops because this would least of
all give way too much activity for to my
opponents so yeah I was thinking on my
feet
huh
how to know where to break down upon
structure for me I read bunch of books
about pond structures and it kind of
felt more natural so that's an advice to
to read more pawn structure based books
just to get a good grip of like
isolation pawns the hanging pawns those
guys so I decided to go this with a 5 to
keep the Bishop to keep some safety over
here which resulted in Bishop g5 and now
black to move what do you want to do
see five where
there was a very nice these two books
that I read winning pawn structures
actually it's called winning pawn
structures and there was another one by
even circle of winning chess middle
games the winning pawn structure one was
by Alexander Putin so those are the two
books that I like through there are many
other good pawn structure books too
I got like understanding there is
another one that I liked understanding
that the pawn playing chess but there's
so many good books
you can't you really can't go wrong so
nice takes d4 1984 is one of the ones to
think about but do you want to take
Knight takes d4 Bishop 64
rook g6 after Queen e5 in the last one
I'll get to it's after this game cuz I
don't I don't want to keep jumping
branch branch if that's okay but
24:54 bishop bishop d4 gives you more
activity so Bishop d4 is the better one
the thing that I worried me with 94 was
if take take stuff with 95 I didn't want
to lose this Bishop so we can't just go
with Bishop d4 take take now you have
sacrificed you sacrificed exchange for a
pawn so you gotta play very dynamically
so your next few moves are kind of
bringing the rook replacing the bishop
so this was not my first choice I would
prefer to win it's very clean instead of
sacrificing but yeah exactly Knight d5
would make it a little more
uncomfortable so my opponent played
clean b3
I didn't want to lose a pawn and I
wanted to keep attacking now this should
be five might be coming up so she tried
so 95-97 doesn't work is because of
Bishop e5 whoops I gave up some oops
but it might go so III now I still have
Bishop e5 g3 Bishop a street you see not
a position gods really active really
fast really dynamic so here white tim
white well why played my g4 take take
and black team of what do you want to do
while I got a while you guys think of
this I'm gonna get back to chat
how about gf6 after Bishop f6 gf6 is
possible but if you really really don't
want to sacrifice there's a big change
yeah gf6 is possible but gf6 makes it
slightly uncomfortable oh I have
greetings from Poland thank you yeah
Knight d4 is also coming up so what do
you want to do 94 maybe Bishop d4 okay
the professor you are right Bishop d4
again because 94 is interesting but you
don't really have a real threat Knight
f3 is not a real threat right now cuz
just Bishop f3 and Queen come and defend
on f1 so you want to simply relocate
your Bishop first and see what he wants
to do what rook t2 can't work because of
loopsy blunder Queen c2 doesn't work
cause you again go over here
so that's why something like crooked one
can work if Brooke is one now there is
you I don't want to say it
alright so it's interesting and you can
clearly see that black has a nice attack
so what do you want to do with black
I see this move being said already in
chat a little bit so
I see okay fragrance you are right lima
dukes you all right okay I think you
guys have a good idea
yeah bring the knight now if you touch
this bishop
now I could have a serious idea of just
queenís tree and Knight f3 coming up so
she played h3 just so that she could try
and not get Knight f3
but after take take now black to move
please find me the win it should be easy
enough ya reckon f1 is suffocating it
right
oh thank you that's very nice of you I'm
glad my explanations make sense all
right I see few people already saying it
all right yeah you guys are all right
you're close to everything and great
so rook goes to f3 and grotty this
lovely maids coming up so my opponent
saw that and she decided to elongate the
game little be a little bit tricky
stopping that getting some room for my
king
and just easy winning so yeah I hope you
guys like this game
this was another very doable game all
right let's look at another one okay so
I've shown you how to play against these
little funny lines with the e5 with d4
so I want to show you another line so
how about early d4 there are early
deforms their castles there B force I
kind of want to show you an advanced
game or two and then we'll go back to
usual Italian alright so in this
advanced game taking is always a good
possibility if you don't want to take
you don't have to but then it might get
uncomfortable with b5 so I always
recommend taking c3 Bishop e7 is also
another possibility but I'm a big push
of a fan Bishop a5 fan and now there are
two main possibilities Queen d4 and
Queen b3
I'm gonna show you both of them because
I had two games in these lines as well
so someone played Queen b3 with me and I
wasn't entirely sure where to put my
queen because neither six I don't want
to do that to defend this pawn so Queen
d7 and Queen f6 are the two
possibilities so my question to you what
do you want to do with black
so
no one no suggestions
yeah Queenie 7 is good I really wanted
to go with Queen f6 so I went with Queen
f6 but I think both of them are good and
doable Queen f6 the main thing is
Castille because a d4 doesn't seem to
work as well d4 is possible but you take
again and if Castle we're getting back
to normal events but if I'm stone work
which abilities are still a little too
funky so you could try just d6 or to
avoid a fives and just try to normal
develop that is a possibility but let's
say castle so what do you want to do
with black
Ondra Queenie salmon is good Knight f6
could be coming up what I was worried
about was queen of squinty 7 there could
be lots of chances with like a5 and
Bishop e3 and those I just didn't really
want to take any chances but it is
always possible so both of them are good
yeah but tonight you can just go to e
seven and depending on how position is
closed or open D five could be useful 96
could be useful
so here 97 is possible but Bishop e6
felt more like tricky and after Bishop
b6 now I want to try this 95 right so
also trying to stop the short about d4
can still happen so let's say d4 happens
now what do you want to do with black
you don't want to be black with advance
I know yeah I saw it I know you do play
advance so not the worst thing to look
at with why it's right the problem is if
something like D sinks mmm the problem
is if you play d6 one thing that could
bother you is could be this d5 but
Bishop g5 is also coming up and not the
most pleasant way yeah I'm not really
the biggest fan of d6 to be honest
because d6 is interesting but gives
white lots and lots of different chances
like first of all this even if Knight
goes to 85 check over here coming here
and this would stop you from castling
and it's very unpleasant so that's why I
went for take and the thing is if you
take back I'm definitely gonna take this
you take I'm taking the bishop that's a
free healthy rook
I'm always hungry for pieces so that's
why the only one to actually consider
deeply z5 now well with black and you
pretty much have two good places to go
queen g6 Knight h4 could be slightly
worrisome because then you have to go
Queen - five also Knight g5 could be a
little bit of threats because if you
take there's rook e1 so that's why I
just chose Queen f5
and here he got two really confused
because he didn't really know what to do
and gave me chances to just get my
pieces out really quickly that Bishop
move is good tactic to know yeah the
bishop coming back to b6 is good good
tactic
what about Bishop g5 which position
Bishop g5 instead of E 5
I think Michelle g5 it's really forces
my hand so just play queen G sinks and
next move I'm gonna try h6 and Knight f6
or eise evan and it seems to be going
decently b5 Queen f5 what's a queen goes
to d1
cuz that's what my opponent did because
she got a little bit of stock he can't
just take it because I take with Knight
and I'm offering Knight exchange and
this is just why it's losing all of her
stall of the center so also not the most
pleasant way to play events for white
all right so he put Queen d1 and the
pawn eater that I am i took this pawn
which was not the best move surprisingly
d5 is the best one because after if you
take here now I develop my pieces with
tempo and this is a pleasant position
for black you just play Castille and you
have some decent targets to go after but
I wanted to cling into the pawns as much
as I could but now white could simply
play rook e1 now this would make it
really complicated for me because if
castle Bishop d3 and then rookie 4 and
you see how everything is like coming up
for the attack so yeah getting a little
sad aren't we
quindi one I know so I think it wasn't
the best idea for whites to play the
early queen bee tree it's doable but
it's not the best idea so my thought
process was if rookie one I could try h6
so there wouldn't be that much threats
because I showed you if Castille I can't
play Queen e6 because of different
versions of my g5 so yeah that was a
little bit of sadness over there so her
key one would be White's best move so if
you're white and if you're looking for
ideas always develop because my opponent
played lights teach you to bring in more
pieces which is cool but not fast enough
so if you're sacrificing pawns pieces
whatever you got to have a good dynamic
play otherwise it's it can get
unpleasant fast so he played nighty -
I'm gonna show you a little bit more
quickly cuz he was pleasant enough to
eat another pond
so I'm tree palms up I already made my
cast all and you know have my queen in a
decent place have everything defended
he tried to do a little bit of
repetition because history pounds down
and I ended up deciding to go for some
exchange again here he could have tried
or like Bishop beats you to keep it a
little bit more pressured up but it's
not it's not the interest for black
that's what I'm trying to say and sorry
scratch that it's not hard for black to
defend the dangers because there could
always be dangerous you could always try
to bring pieces you could always try to
create some sort of an attack but you
just if black plays carefully blacks
doing good so I see there is a chat
going on croissants which I really want
right now some ham cheese and crisps on
whoo well I'm getting hungry
I'm already eating bunch of pawns so I'm
gonna go quickly on this cuz it didn't
really have that's much to look at just
some stuff to be careful about because
we don't want to lose our advantage so a
little bits of Treecko over here a
little bits a tricot over there winning
more material and it's just winning
eventually so
all right I am glad this one is over
there was another advanced I played here
right in the same position so queen bee
tree is what we looked at but d4 is the
main one and d4 take Queen b3 is another
possibility cast though like fast cast
though is possible to Queen then you
come back and then their queen bee trees
could be or just take over here which
I've played so much fun to it recently
and terrible play by white cool yeah
right okay
so possible ways to play this here is
still to bring out the night no more
Queen touch but that's getting really
funny isn't it alright so let's go back
to the game that I had with queen bee
tree now so in this game I played Queen
e7 instead of Queen f6 and I played my
queen bees Bishop b6 d6 and I got myself
into this ePHI position so here black to
move what do you want to do I missed a
slight I missed I missed the best move
because I didn't want to risk too much
but let's see if you guys can figure it
out
yeah so 95 is definitely one of the
candidates so it's like the game here
right now is between 95 and 95 so what
do you want to do now professor
we don't resign no resigning so in the
game I went with 95 and fun fact this
actually was one of my norm games and I
won this game yeah this was actually
last round for my second norm I remember
it because I was I had the flight like
three hours of scheduled after this game
to go plane asked Austria Bundesliga and
I was like oh my god I'm not gonna make
my flight I'm gonna miss my flight
I made the flight I made to my straight
Bundesliga so yeah here I played 95 and
like I remember in this game I needed a
win to get the norm otherwise I would
just get another wgm norm so I really
wanted to play it both safe and kind of
funky so Knight a5 I didn't trust that
night a5 would be good enough because I
thought if I get myself into this
position and I thought I can take and
maybe like you should try and exchange a
little bit I thought this is a bad end
game and I don't want to get into it and
I was kind of right it's not the most
pleasant tent game but a6 is the move
that I missed to force tricks to
exchange it and now even if you take it
over here you just play 97 and I just
wasn't comfortable enough with the same
game because in 2016
I had sad and the game
techniques and that um that the title
the game that we're seeing is not the
game that is shown sorry this was a game
against m4 coupe ski in 2016
anyways alright so she in this position
I just went to Knight takes e5 and
that's really nice why not I wanted to
get some palms and I didn't see any
immediate immediate Trev and I thought
well this is still doable and up until
this point I thought Knight c3 take
Bishop b2 I thought about it for c1 I
always have Bishop d2 and if you keep
trying to like hunt my Bishop I'll just
go for the Queen exchange and I thought
this was pretty doable and there's still
lots of dangers and threats but it was
my norm game so I was willing to bet on
my crazy edible pieces anyways now 85
did feel like a little bit of wrong but
I feel like 95 maybe taking wasn't a
smart idea but and then again like take
take
even if Bishop f7 is just King f8 and
everything is safe
so King f8 now it's even better for me
because I'm actually not out of this
fire line so I don't know it's felt
really yeah the pieces my opponent's
pieces are always edible that's rule
number one
yeah I was a brave kid right give me
this position right now and
I not do the same things so one and then
oh I remember that in the game after
Bishop b2 oh I'm winning all the pieces
so thank you opponent and I slightly I
rookie a e1 would have made it more
difficult for me because like this is
still like you have a rook Bishop Knight
and like three pawns in exchange for
Queen but it is kind of unpleasant and I
remember my opponents felt like he was
losing and he just played the other
group do you want and I was like great
I'll just eat another Rick so I also get
slightly lucky but I feel like even if
she kept his rook this is still like I
want to be black in this position
regardless because I just get my night
out give me like three moves I get this
night out somewhere just fish about and
some g6 throwing the g6 and King g7 in
there if I can get my pieces out
this isn't still advantage for black so
he he just felt like he was losing and
he did some lovely blunders that made my
life slightly easier and instead of
being Wondrich one Bishop one night and
three pounds instead of a point now I
got another Rick too so thanks for that
but but yeah so this was very pleasant
and I want this and I remember even
after winning this my rating was to 398
life and I still was like I still waited
two more to cross and first round of
Austria Bundesliga I got that and I
crossed and I got really hammered and it
was good it was a good memory crossing
always crossing the street like 2,300
2,400 are always really good
so super gyms 26 plus no I I have drawn
a bunch but I don't think I have beaten
yeah a little bit it felt like you did
but I mean it was a advantage position
anyways yeah
alright so let's look at another usual
Italian one okay so this was the
experience with lovely advance now ooh
let me show you a game that I had just a
normal Italian well normal closed
Italian d3 so over the years I've played
around with moves a lot like I've played
early cast Oh early d6 but the one that
I absolutely like is with a six because
with a six I actually get a little bit
of chance to explore more ideas I'm
gonna show you one of these ideas right
now let me just so Bishop b3 is one of
the ideas Castle is another it's kind of
both transposes the one game that I
absolutely liked OOP this one and this
one
so yeah so I mixed a bunch of the games
for you to show you so let's say
opponent was a Bishop d3 you go to put
your Bishop on a7 and I like to play
these six first the wait for you to see
what you want to do if you play h3 so
it's better to play Knight d2 first with
white because it kind of forces my hand
to play Castille h6 does there's no need
for h6 Castille if rook e1 there are
lines with 94 and then like dude there's
this lovely line that's you get to play
f5 but she's I like it point out so
that's why a lot of players with white
like the next three moves they kind of
mix it up first night teach you then
they play like h3 after Castle so over
the years I developed this tiny trick
which I try a lot and blitz more than I
should
with so even if you play like a street
first or 92 but moreover h3 because when
you play a street I'm never gonna have
this Knight g4 9 h6 so I might as well
play h6 first and now if you play Knight
d2 I like to play g5 so that's something
that I've tried a little here in them
and I'm gonna show this to you really
quickly you can try this a lot but you
the one thing that you do have to be
careful when g5 is make sure you know
what you're doing because if why it gets
d4 it could get slightly unpleasant so
I've had experience with Knight C for
lots nine-ish too is another possibility
but you still do get g4 because there is
no f3 I like this light d2 because it
takes away the chances of immediate
Bishop e3
so let's say I might see four so Bishop
III could be coming up g4 take take
Bishop III and I'm getting my chance to
I'm still going to do long Castille
eventually and I already have a somewhat
decent attack so yeah I wanted to show
this to you a little bit okay take you
have Knight take then you do your long
cast though if Knight goes to f5 there
are some cool lines with that but this
was a game that I played in in 2012
I've been trying this a lot and blitz
and wrap it so I have looked over what
I've played previously to yeah if if
this if they play a street too fast it
does give you the chance to start doing
some attack on the kingside so that's
something that I liked do I have any
events gambit games to show I just did I
I have more but there are more like
online games yeah any questions about
endgame my choice is always the the
risky one as a beginner as like the the
first book to read alright so back to
this game this game I just wanted to
show you the idea I didn't want to get
too deep into it but just the ideas that
you could try out with this g5 g4 so the
main idea is that just have to so you
delay your Castle you play a six first
you play your a six early on
you say if you're you put your bishop in
the safe place then you play your d6 and
then you play your age six because
you're never gonna play Knight to g4
anymore after h3 and now if Knights d2
you can't play your g5 so that's what I
wanted to show if you play it on
anywhere well only online these days and
leave it in the comments below
I do come and read back some of the
comments so it would be nice to see how
you guys played so let's let me show you
another game with rook e1 so this game
was also kid or sapling I I learned a
lot about what I liked and what I didn't
like an Italian those years like 2012-13
because I was starting to actually
understand some of the dynamic and
strategic aspects of chests more in
depth so that was that was like my big
revelation in Italian to play like a six
first and like um coming up with this
tiny tiny little tricks yeah I did say
they were his endgame book to answer in
a tux
all right back to some move moves with
chess so here g5 it doesn't feel as good
anymore first of all there is d4 second
of all I don't think this works but you
still have to keep an eye on it some
might be a little bit troublesome but
there's always rip create so not as much
because there's also Bishop h3 coming so
just just some stuff to keep in mind but
I think the the best one for white is d4
and it's not another tiny strategy
attack is if you're planning on
attacking in my King cider Queen side
it's best if the center is already
closed up so if the center is still
mobile like this and there
of changes that could be made in center
and it's not best idea to attack in the
one side it was slightly different if
the night is on d2 because now d4 you
would be also giving up the pawn with
light so that's something to keep in
mind alright so I didn't want to play
this g5 anymore just normal cast oh and
here there are there are so many
different lines there is Bishop e6 there
is 97 there is Knight age 5 I think
those are the big ones there's roughly 8
so because all right so what idea is to
get that night to here or there and try
and have sanic organized and attack like
that just getting the pieces out and
eventually d4 so that's why it's idea I
did my eye I did follow the invitational
tournament
[Music]
alright so the my favorite one so far
I tried this Knight age 5 and it's just
not really what it didn't really satisfy
me so I want to try Bishop e6 Bishop e6
night f1 seems to be the most common one
because right now d4 doesn't work
because I can just take and take back so
night have fun preparing on d4 with
black there are many different lines to
do here again the many different move
orders so you can try so the basic idea
is with black you also want to play d5
it's just a matter of when so in this
game I decided to just go with d5 right
away take take
um 95s don't really work because of this
lovely sacrifice and picking up the
wreck and so my opponents White Queen e2
now she's threatening to take on e5 so I
went with Queen f6 there are some
possibilities of f6 but if you're gonna
play up six it's better if your pawn is
on h7 so there are no chances of like
because this this diagonal would be
super weak if you play up six right now
so better not to do that
alright oh I'm getting so many
positivity is in chat thank you thank
you everyone
96 is also possible but it is possible
to play d5 with your Knights still on c6
so okay Queenie - I went with Queen f6
and then I just put the Queen on g6
because of this lovely diagonal and now
black to move what do you want to do
yeah the sacrifice is pretty nice right
so blacks ammo how do you want to spice
it up a little
nice f4 is interesting but you do have
something better so 94 is a slightly
premature because if you play Knight f4
now you're just inviting to take and
could also take over here
but perhaps something like 94 and you
are giving your opponent chances to
centralize a little bit so is there a
rule to purchase 25 not necessarily you
just have to be careful to not hang your
e5 pawn oops
so instead of a nice f4 I wanna drug the
eight because if you take now I can also
take the drug for take here and f2 is
falling so exchanging giving getting f2
is much better than a 5 specially
because right now I have these guys
under attack
so rook thi just basically put more
defense on d5 so my pieces won't be
defenseless another thing that I've been
talking a lot about is not to leave your
pieces hanging and we did a full 1012
puzzles on it on our twitch channel with
me just on Sunday so if you feel like
watching more puzzles go on our twitch
and only check that out so it was a lot
about just not please leaving your
pieces and pawns hanging so here my
knight and eventually my bishop would be
a little bit hanging so I just brought
more enforcement Bishop c2 no blacks you
move what do you want to do
yeah taking these three pawn also at the
end
yep loose pieces drop off yep thank you
fragrance Thank You professor yeah I
five so f five is cool too
another possibility to think about this
F six but not my style
divorce coming up so f five and so
taking is is still not the best idea
because simply rook e8 and now I want to
just move this bishop and this guy is
falling the Queen doesn't really have
any decent place to go
so nine eighty five doesn't work so my
opponents right d4e for now what are you
gonna do with this night
ninety-two there's III to take Europe is
your night falls so she went with my g1
and you can already see how it's
everything is getting so suffocated she
could try Knight takes e4 take down ith
for Queen f7 not Queenie for and I think
this was the better one because now this
is going over here and over here so I
kind of have to play g5 and after this
if I take it there is perpetual there is
the chance of perpetual and if not I
could try for like work f2 and this is
still making things very unpleasant and
why it could actually have more game so
there is the chance of 94 as white I
think you should try that you should
have tried that but after E for yeah
after E for nice g1 and you can already
see that black has advantage so how do
you wants to play it out how about 95 95
I think I mean you kind of have to take
it
and
[Music]
this pond seems so wonderful and you've
already opened up my bishop as well so I
do know that I had a talent age how
exactly to use it well
easiest case I can just relocate the
night and go after this pawn with my
Kruk t5 that's the easiest one yeah
so night g1 the easiest way that I
wanted to go about it was just to keep
more defense with my nights over here
everything's super defended
now what's your next move if you find
this move it's a very nice mix of
strategy and dynamic so
yeah fine this move and you should be
good with black
is it wise for black now it's for black
b5 I think b5 is interesting bishop p8
c6 first yeah professor you got it
c6 first with idea Bishop p8 because
think about it logically this Bishop is
dead over here so might as well get
isn't the better better diagonal so c6
here Knight coming to f3 was actually
the best option because you can't
whoops because you can't take because
you just go to the endgame so that's
something that he should have tried but
she went with Queen f1 and then Bishop
eh now what black C move what do you
want to do so why do you guys think I'm
gonna tell share a little of psychology
aspects so when you already have a good
position like this with black or with
any color it's really hard for the
opponent to actually come up with the
best moves it takes a lot a lot of a lot
of energy and a lot of actually good
chess knowledge to come up with really
the best moves for whites because why I
did have some chances that earlier
sacrificed with 94 that we saw again
Knight f3 dots we saw before Queen f1
there are chances to get your pieces
active and get the pieces out with white
but yeah it is not the most pleasant one
here so
black to move what do you want to do I
see some c5 no your game is on the King
slide so yeah yeah I just saw its h5
said by Elia yeah that's fine I try this
is a good one because if it's black to
move again you're just gonna eat the
piece why not so a short for white is
pretty much the only move now now what
you wants to do with black I've seen
this move else slightly earlier on on
I've seen this move earlier on chat but
no one's saying it right now Toronto you
try to think again about the same ideas
that you had before h 5 h h4 h 5 h 5 h
4y a fragrance thank you for the
rewarding you can't think properly when
you're under the pressure there coach
so keep the pressure on yeah that is my
one of my main things queen g4 is
definitely interesting but queen g4 you
could give the chance Forbes nope that
is a little too much on G Bishop g5 and
I'm not entirely sure how you want to
continue the attack
I guess f4 but I don't really want to
get the show on g5 cuz then some f3
ideas could emerge so maybe not Queen g4
yeah okay I see the ideas I shake yeah
III so III is the best one because
simply you can't take it I'm gonna eat a
piece and same if you take with Bishop
so in order to not lose a piece you
cannot touch this pond you have to wait
for me to take it so then you take it
back with Queen and you're defending
your night so she tried to c4 so if I
move the night let's say I move the
night somewhere this should be three
could be possible but now now we've
talked about we have talked about and
I've shown this move a little bit
earlier and what do you want to do with
black yeah III was cool right another
aspect that III is that you block off
that Bishop so what do you want to do
yeah we do have a chess960 tournaments
tomorrow to which I will play from 1:30
to 3:30 I believe and then I'm going to
study a little bit from my organic
chemistry exam tomorrow night and I have
that exam from 6:00 to 9:00 p.m.
lovely right
what about 9f four I just take it F for
for white it's black to move so if you
play F for your queen is a little bit
under attack be careful taking on f2
doesn't really work queen takes you want
you want to keep the position all
tangled up
so nope not at four so another great
difference that this panel III makes
this bishop can no longer come to g5 how
can you use this nope not night at four
thank you I doing it all the luck for
the exam now think about how this Bishop
being stuck here helps you Queen f6 you
have the right idea but not the best
move all right so I got the best move
Queen g4 is the best one good one okay
so in queen g4 the best one no more
Bishop g5 so it's pretty much a game
already over just few more moves she
took the bait now how do you want to win
this game you guys already set this move
again before so I'm just going to show
it because I already saw lots of
recommendations on it
f4 now now it's everything is happening
really nicely everything is under attack
lovely right if you take I just take
that one first
and taking everything - and this Bishop
is the nightmare so she tried Knight g1
I just simply took this guy and took the
other one too
I'm sure something like this also is
very pleasant because this is coming up
but I went with Bishop here after he
okay one last move for you guys to to
find two moves basically you do this
move she does that you do that and it's
winning I mean this is already winning
but we can safely resign
perhaps tree yeah good one thank you
thank you grateful thank you Illya
doctor take g2 and time to go home
after take just Bishop F tree picking up
that guy picking up that guy picking up
everything and even if you try something
like King g'wan I'm sure this is still
super winning can't they just take here
can I just take here everything is
winning isn't it yeah all right so yeah
this was another game that I wanted to
show you so I've covered some of the
main big main lines in Italian and we
went over some events and I try to keep
it personal between my games and you
know stay nice and oscar games so
hopefully you guys learned more about
how to play with black and what to look
out for with whites and I hope you
enjoyed it I'll see you again tomorrow
and the day after
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you